first this might surprise you according
to our commander-in-chief
the greatest threat to our service men
and women
it's not china it's not russia it's not
iran and north korea
it's not radical islamic terrorists it's
not
nuclear war no according to president
sippy cup
joe the greatest threat to our military
is global warming and he was not joking
take a look
we must all commit to an ambitious
climate action
if we're going to prevent the worst
impacts of climate change limiting
global warming warming to no more than
1.5
degrees celsius lead the global the
global transition to clean energy
technology
you know when i went over in the tank in
the pentagon when i first
was elected vice president with
president obama
the military sat us down to let us know
what the greatest threats facing america
were the greatest physical threats
this is not a joke you know what the
joint chiefs told us the greatest threat
facing america was
global warming okay
uh in just a few days that guy will sit
down
with the hostile actor from the hostile
regime
of russia vladimir putin you know the
country that just hacked
our energy and our beef industries
and i fear that vladimir will eat joe's
lunch embarrass us all that is not good
for this country it is not good for the
world
and vladimir will see what we all see
that joe biden is frail
weak and a cognitive mess who can do
little more than
read far left talking points on a
teleprompter
and he actually struggles to do that but
believe it or not is vice president
kamala harris
well she might actually be even more
incompetent i know
hard to believe because her trip to
latin america was an unmitigated
disaster and biden's border czar
struggled to answer basic questions
about the border crisis she doesn't seem
to understand what's actually going on
at the border
she flat out refused to actually visit
or commit to visiting the border
well i haven't been to europe either i
haven't been to the moon either
when she was openly criticized and
lectured by latin american leaders
both before during and after her trip
it was so bad even fake news cnn even
they were complaining one headline
reading quote
kamala harris is having a bad week and
it's only wednesday
even white house staffers were according
to reports multiple reports
quote perplexed by kamala's terrible
performance
one democratic strategist telling the
hill quote she will be haunted by this
trip
and this issue for as long as she is in
politics
and needless to say kamala's trip to
guatemala and mexico
didn't do a single thing to solve the
crisis now if she actually bothered to
visit the border she could see the
situation with her own two eyes
i've been there i don't know 12 13 14
times
helicopter horseback all-terrain vehicle
out on foot
watching people arrested drug warehouses
tunnels yeah i learn more every time i
go
if any from anyone from the white house
is watching this program tonight
maybe you can show it to kamala so she
can learn something
griff jenkins yeah he was in the middle
of the rio grande all day
and all around him were migrants just
wading across the river
broad daylight you're looking at a
non-stop never-ending stream of migrants
just walking right into the country
nobody's turning them away
they get the help of human traffickers
mexican cartels
operating in broad daylight and breaking
our laws
and not respecting our borders or
sovereignty they're not being turned
away they're not being sent back
instead these migrants including many
elderly individuals young children
they're now being housed and fed and
they get their health care and education
with your hard-earned tax dollars
all because joe and kamala both told
them to come
and promised a pathway to citizenship
we'll have well over 2 million illegal
immigrants
cross this border illegally this year
that'll be a 20 to 30 year record
in doing so they are disrespecting
everything
regarding our laws and our constitution
they're enriching
the cartels they're costing all of us a
fortune
they are cutting the line in front of
legal immigrants
who are jumping through hoops to do it
the right way and follow the law
but joe biden kamala harris no they're
unable
unwilling to solve the crisis they're
actually aiding and abetting the law
breaking
as a result they're hurting the country
here hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else